we have put a in place protections for
the tsangas forest in alaska the world's
largest intact
temperate rainforest and today i'm
announcing
a new plan to conserve global forest
which will bring together a full range
of u.s government tools diplomatic
financial and policy to halt forest laws
restore critical carbon sinks and
improve land management
through this plan
the united states will help the world
deliver
on our shared goal of halting natural
forest loss
and restoring
at least an additional 200 million
hectares of forest and other ecosystems
by the year 2030.
this plan is the first of its kind
and taking a whole government approach
and working in our case with congress to
deploy
up to 9 billion
in u.s funding through 2030 to conserve
and restore our forests and mobilize
billions more from our partners
as part of this we're going to work to
ensure markets recognize the true
economic value of natural carbon sinks
and motivate governments landowners and
stakeholders to prioritize conservation
we'll work to align the private sector
investment flows in our climate concern
conservation goals including
reducing the drivers of deforestation
creating sustainable supply chains
pursuing more sustainable commodity
sourcing
and every step will work in partnership
with the people
most impact by deforestation and most
experienced
in sustainable land management
local communities indigenous people
local governments civil societies to
make sure our approaches are effective
and focused on the needs of vulnerable
populations
preserving forests and other ecosystems
can and should
play an important role in meeting our
ambitious climate goals as part of the
net zero emissions strategy we all have
and the united states is going to lead
by our example at home
and support other forested nations in
developing countries and setting
and achieving ambitious action
to conserve and restore these carbon
sinks
i'm confident we can do this
all we need to do is summon the will
to do what we know is right and we know
is necessary he knows in our capacity
so
as simple as it sounds i think it is
this simple
let's get to work we can do this
and it'll have a generational impact
thank you
thank you